OOOOHH Boooyyyy!!
HEY
"Guts and Glory" is a video game
We're doing a video game now BOOYYS and GIIRRLS (oh great poods)
It's a really fun game
It got updated, I thought we'd check it out together
Aaaand let's go
See now we have Earl available
That's hilarious
Because Earl has puns
Let's see what Earl can do
What the fuck is this ?
Well I'm enjoying myself (He like to see earl twerking)
*Denzel Curry- Ultimate*
I'm a natural born.. game .. OH
Here we go.. Here we.. Earl
I've just muted the volume of the game
What is happening ?
OOOOOOH Earl is off
YEEESSS!
Earl is the best driver in the world
Earl knows exactly what he's doing (RIP stuck)
OOOOOOH
OH MY GOD .. Earl has got a new ability! (Pewds can't drive)
Well that's a nice fucking split right there
Oh we can play with the car
Oh my god ! That's amaz-
The Yang family!
leeeet's go to school
Where the hell are they going ?
Ohhhh no Yang family ? please
Ohhh Yang family!
Back flip yang family
FUCK YEAH!
(WHAT THE FUUUCK)
OHH WHAT THE SSSHHHIIITTTT?!
Oh what the shit !
Oh no !
Let's give that another go
This is awesome
The yang family they just wanted to drive their car
But they were about to find out, that driving car isn't too easy
*Beedy- "Thrsdays 8/7c" Album Intro*
Old school intro
We gotta get you to school son
If you're late you get a spanking
And mommy will watch (can i watch too  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) )
Oh No
OOOOH OH OH
The kid is almost falling out
The kid is still in
The kid is uuugh .. The kid is dead
(BYE BARRY !)
Wife is giving me a blow job .. This is great  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) pewds like it ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Oh god.. Where do we go now ?
*"The Matrix" (1999)*
JUMPSCARE !
This is the construct
How the fuck am I supposed to get there ?
Oh .. Well that answers that question
Here we go
It's so hard to control Earl
He is out of control .. Get it ?
Hey look at that !
*mine*
What the fuck was that !?
Jesus!
Oh there is mines evreeeeh... Pewds going to lost his mind
Here we go can't hit shit boy .. Oh Fuck
This why you should not drink and drive
*silence. almost*
*r.i.p headphones :(*
*R.I.P Headphone users*
*Laughs because a man exploded*
*laughs bcz it was hilarious lul*
Oh he went face-in on that o--
EY MY CAR ! .. Oh hell yeah
Now that is what i'm talking about honey ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Check out our new house
That did not work the way i wanted
What the fuck is that wheel doing
How is... How ?
Look at this look at this... This will be cool
HELL Yeah!
Oh Wow !
*Gonna Fly Now (Theme From "Rocky")
And from that day they were known as the dolphin family
There it is
Doing good, Oh not the cannons
BOOST!
Shit!
You can do it Earl .. You can do it Earl .. You got this
Alright, Here we go cannons
BOOOOOOOOOOOOST!
Oh Goddamn it
*Soo close pewds*
Oh ooh fuck that hurts like inside that hurts (Just like my relationship)
Here we go .. Boost
Can't hit shit boyyy
I'm fast as fuck (Earl is sanic !!11)
Aaaaah .. Wooooh I became a fuckin' crate
He looks like a dolphin.. Got stuck in one of those.. Aaah beer plastic pieces you know? And can't get out
Come on you fuckin' bitch
I fuckin' got this
Do you fuckin know who I'm ?
Wooooh boy
OOOOOOOOHHHHHH
Oh what the fuck happened ?
No no .. Control control control .. There it is
Full control everyone
This is how it's done
You think I need fuckin' wheels ?
Fuck You !
Shit Shit Shit .. Oh I'm still .. Still going bitches !
Aaaaaaah .. Never mind
Alright, Can we do this .. Can we do this ?
*satanic music*
Oh i'm going so fast .. I'm going so fuckin' fast
Ooooooh .. Oh oh my god (Jumpscare EVERYONE ! )
This scared me so much. Jesus Christ .. What the fuck !
I don't really need to play horror games to get scared guys it's fine.
Okay, Here we go .. We gonna have so much fucking speed now
Oh Come on! (That's why pewds hate barrel)
Here it is .. Don't get jump scared .. Don't get jump scared .. Come on I got this no problem
No fuckin' problem .. 100 per-  plaaaah
Jesus Christ Come ooooh
Oh huuuuh hoh hoh hoh hoh hoh oh  .. Oh nooooo FUUUUUCK
*Enya- Only Time*
What the fuck is that!?
No! no no I didn't get the checkpoint .. I didn't get the ..
NOOOOOO! S-Stop
YEEEEES!
Alright, Here we go .. Here we go
First try .. First try .. First try .. First try .. Fuck Yes
Oooohooh my god !
Oh my god , What the fuck is.. What the fuck is this then !?
Alright, Boy
*IT'S TIMMY PEWDS!!!*
Sit tight you fuckin' bitch
Hell Yeah!
Oh god there's arrows
Oh my god there's .. This is ridiculous.. This is ridiculous
No .. Not today
Here we go .. Here we go
Dodge them
Shit shit shit shit
Dodge them .. Dodge them
Dodging left and right son
Neeaaa.. Fuckin' hell, That was so good
Legit trying my fuckin' hardest
*Intense montage* Come on... Come... ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*Intense montage*
Oh That dodge (such pro)
Oh my god
*intense montage*
Here we go
*Intense montage*
Oooooh
Oooooh.. Ooohooh
*Intense montage*
Ohooh
YEEEES!
*Intense montage*
*Credits rolling*
SUBSCRIBE TO LEAFY!!!!
Oooh.Keep going! .. Keep going son! .. Keep fuckin' going
Jesus Christ .. If you die now I swea.. Oh my god !
Keep going.. Keep going .. Keep going
Nooo.. Oh bail bail
We got it .. We got this .. We got this .. We got this
We just need speed .. We just k...
*swedish*
*it was you're only shot*
I gotta do all that again !?
*ITS NEVER 2 LATE*
This is stupid.
*Another intense montage*
*elephant noise*
That's it
Ow.. Keep going
Ignore the pain .. Ignore the pain
Hell Yea... ARE YOU FUCKIN' KIDDING ME RIGHT FUCKIN' NOW
ARE YOU FUCKIN' SERIOUS!?
The goal is right there
And my son lives!
*Frustration*
Oh my god (kill me)
*Realization*
This is stupid (oh it is)
That's it .. That's fuckin' it
Yes.. No .. Oh !
No .. Hooooh .. Hooooh .. Haaaah
*Crying real tears*
*CRY BABY*
Yeeeees
Yeeees !!
HAAAAAAH
*Mighty Harambe Roar*
HOOOOH
HOOOHOOOHOHOHOH *Creepy*
YEEEEEESS!
Aaaaall part of the plan
Yeeeaaaa..NGGGGGGH
*He is pissed*
Ainsley: Felix wait .. No Felix stay calm , please (pewds has no control of himself)
Ainsley: Naa.. (Last word) :(
*R.I.P Ainsley :(*
*Sad music*
*Realizes what he has done*
No
Ainsley
#pray4ainsley
*Crying*
*It's 2 late pewds*
Ainsley
*Crying in shock*
What have I done!
*time to replace Ainsley srry Pewds*
*sad music continues*
*sadpoods.jpg*
*R.I.P Ainsley*
Rip Ainsley
You will be missed
*the face of regret*
*Contemplates life*
*Goodbye Ainsley :(*
*sad outro*
Can I get a rip in chat:
*Sad Music Continue*
goto the next video ya lil bitch
rip Ainsley -Hex